un joli dans le casinotier je suis votre
idole seul juin 2001 ça vous embête
survie votre âge non blancs fou et j'ai
17 ans l'avait dit que ça va vite de la
grande île fait un nom et vous êtes une
famille catteau bourges
oui vous vous compterez des cvg mais
père officier de marine
charline j'étais marine marchande son
père pour moi ce soir
famiglia ses traditionnelles où il n'est
pas bien vu d'être artiste faire que par
être pas du tout à supporter d'être
artiste professionnel way artistes comme
ça ça va
voilà vous savez quand on avait un
talent caché dans la famille de sylvie
joly fallait exercer en secret voilà un
amateur en la matière est il votre
arrière grand oncle eu par exemple de la
comédie française la personne n'en
parlait c'est à dire que ce site et les
travaux d'un grand mère qui était la
comédie française avec un pseudonyme et
ils étaient cinq enfants quand on
demande à mon arrière-grand-mère combien
vous aviez dit enfants elle les 4 1 sur
les photos de famille est une tâche
d'encre à la place de cet homme là n'a
changé quand même regarder et clara
morgane lp bx descendants ses parents
avec son jus dit voilà papa maman on a
décidé avec grec de faire du x mais mes
enfants ce par un problème parce qu'il
aime ça a changé quand même parce qu'à
l'époque de sidi la comédie française
était mal vu des comptes s'il était du
xv a trop grand pour lui vous dites
alors un truc un peu quand même un peu
gonflé vous dites il est plus difficile
de s'imposer quand on vient d'un milieu
aisé
oui je crois que c'est plus moi je suis
d'accord avec devancé celle ci vaut
mieux un ami les aristos et
je n'arrive pas à pleurer sur l'enfant
d'une famille aisée même quand il est
contrarié c'est précisément ça qui est
dur c'est qu'on pleure pas sur ces
précise celle qui tourne alors qu'as tu
à l'école le gosse de riche moi j'aurais
jamais voulu être un gosse de riche ce
que le gosse de riche à lui dit attends
tu vas quand même pas de plaindre un des
parents ils ont l'inconvénient est tout
et souvent il a tout sauf l'amour
il a beau sac et la sac en cuir il a des
beaux stylos mais il a pas d'amour et
celui là il va vous devez malheureux que
que des enfants de bons rendre qui n'a
pas d'amour
évidemment là qu'est malade alors
vocation comique assez précoce
vous dites je suis né clown et comme
vous êtes croyante vous avez considéré
très tôt votre vocation c'est un devoir
d'une certaine façon d'exploiter votre
talent comique c'est une espèce de
volonté mystique pour faire du bien aux
gens oui c'est vrai un moment donné je
me suis dit bah oui c'est vrai que sur
ce dernier on a l'impression qu'on est
doué pour quelque chose et que ça fait
10 pas du mal aux gens
eh bien oui exactement alors étant
enfant ont été renvoyés de cette
institution religieuse nous et vous êtes
retrouvés dans la classe de bernadette
chirac est et comment hilary kole
j'avais pièces jaunes
non non elle était
élève bonne bonne élève ouais ce qui
était facile le son par rapport à l'or
après le bac vos parents vous interdise
de devenir actrice et votre père vous
dit puisque tu veux tu exprimes état qu
être avocate et dans la boue choisissez
celui qui habite le plus près de chez
vous c'est maîtrise orné vous saviez
quand même mais ça avait été l'avocat de
pétain et tout ça oui oui oui j'allais
après on peut être l'avocat de pétards
marquer mais tout le monde a droit à un
avocat mais il avait quand même des
idées à ces réactionnaires maîtrise
hormis non c'est pas moi je vais tout le
monde mais didier contradictoires moi je
conduis journée il était tombé amoureux
de son client
vrai de ce qui arrive là est vraiment un
libyen 6 mai il était fasciné par
l'homme qu'il a mais qu'il avait défendu
oui alors vous réalisez qu'au delà des
effets de manche
il est comme des tonne de paperasse dans
ce boulot d'avocat et puis la
responsabilité puisque vous dites si je
fais pas rire soir c'est pas grave mais
si le mec qui prend dix ans parce que
j'ai mal plaisait s'emmerde à dire que
ça puisqu'elle va la peine de mort enfin
village est bien trop de responsabilités
pour moi j'ai fait ça l'avocat peut
alors être mariée depuis sept ans pour
vous annoncer à votre mari finalement
voulais être comédienne quoi si vous
aviez ça vraiment chevillée au corps
quoi et votre mari dit oui
je savais que tu étais artistes vous
êtes vraiment oui c'est assez vrai c'est
une charte
j'ai du mal quoi alors je veux dire que
j'ai dis bah vous êtes du bassin de 40
ans qui est avec vous même un peu puis
saint jean à l'aja il ya un bien vient
au spectacle ils veulent en vo spectacle
il vit alors comment vous voyez votre
mari dire c'est à dire qu'il est le seul
dans ce que je veux dire ça mais ça nous
encourage c'est normal qu'ils n'ont
cessé mais j'ai souvent âgés chaque fois
que j'ai vu sylvie j'étais à côté de son
mari et respire avec celui là ouais de
toute façon s'ils n'étaient pas là
moi j'aurais j'aurais pas fait ça je
suis arrivé un ouais c'est trop dur ce
qui est dit sur la culture
vous êtes une fille courageuse tout ce
qu'on vous décidez de devenir comédienne
vous pourrez les causes au cours simon
de l'école de tania betsch bas j'étais à
l'école de ta diabel la chaux va lui
arriver quelque chose comme si vous
prenez des cours avec avec le cours
simon par exemple d'aller au petit
conservatoire de huy jvania wyss anyama
la fania devient cabral à jouer du
classique au départ joyeuse et ce qu ils
voulaient s'est pas préparé des scènes
c'est cela oui je voudrais pas passer
travel a largement dépassé la ssii que
la vraiment faire et aux coursives où
j'avais trente 30 bergère n'en font que
je fasse allait passer célimène était ça
marche pas je rien à [ __ ] c'est le
début les années 70 ce que vous décidez
ma carrière comique
alors là oui c'est dit allons-y essayons
saga que je fais oui oui c'est
magnifique avec des rideaux bleus
content de lui une sorte de parasite
agréable on l'a fait elle va être juste
avant le secret quand même s'est jamais
cherché à être drôle parce que là c'est
fichu r oui c'est non c'est vrai je
pense pas que c'est ce que c'est oui
c'est ce que croit et il pense à la
chose je pense que si on est si on est
surpris en flagrant délit de vouloir
être drôle c'est moi bien que d'être
directement drôle bien sûr
venu de là
il ya les bus et les spectacles au
casino de paris jusqu'au 16 mai à mes
yeux